Killua
How does a character go from here - to here?
- But maybe, this isn’t even the correct
question to ask here. Because bad guy going
good is not exactly a revolutionary trope
in storytelling. So, maybe the better question
to ask here, is why Killua’s complete change
of character feels so incredibly authentic
and natural and why his story is so strongly
relatable.
There is a reason why Killua Zoldyck is by
far the most beloved character in a story,
that Yoshihiro Togashi has filled to the brim
with fascinatingly complex & intriguing characters.
Being cool, charismatic and at times a bit
creepy, Killua is already a through and through
enjoyable character, even just at a superficial
level. Being the second protagonist of the
story, we accompany him on his journey with
Gon through the dangerous world of Hunter
x Hunter and enjoy watching him grow stronger
and more mature - a typical shounen adventure.
But, as is the case with almost all characters
in this beautifully crafted series, you have
to dig just a tiny bit deeper into the structure
of the plot to discover that Killua’s character
is pretty much as complex and multi-layered
as it gets. Killua’s arc contains a number
of underlying themes, that I think are all
worth looking at in detail to truly understand
his character. This includes his quest to
break free from the chains of his family,
developing self-worth, seeking freedom of
will and ultimately finding his purpose in
life - all elements, that Togashi has not
only connected to the plot at hand and Killua’s
journey through the world, but that he also
has interconnected and woven into each other
to form a complete and organic feeling character
that is shaped by his upbringing, but also
his environment. As we have discussed in the
last video, the overall theme of Hunter Hunter
is humanity and what it means to be human
in a superhuman world, and Togashi uses the
classic trope of the buddy story to contrast
both Killua and Gon and their growth and coming-of-age
from a realistic and credible perspective.
Thus, instead of going chronologically, which
might feel a bit too much like a recap of
the story, I think it is best to look at the
relationship between Killua and Gon first,
to give you a better idea of the overall character
and then delve deeper into the details of
his character arc. Before we can discuss the
dreadfully dramatic dream Team that is Killua
and Gon however, I believe that we have to
first take a closer look at Killua’s upbringing
to really understand how he became the unsettlingly
dark boy we first meet during the hunter exam.
Killua’s tragic childhood and the complex
relations within his family are something
that is revealed only in increments by Togashi,
while we travel from arc to arc. While we
personally get to see his family home and
parts of his relatives in the Zoldyck family
arc after the hunter exam takes place, many
crucial details surrounding the family are
revealed in other arcs. Killua’s relationship
with Illumi for instance is introduced during
the hunter exam arc, his grandfather appears
for the first in the Yorknew arc to take out
Chrollo and Alluka is only introduced after
the Chimera Ant arc. If you sometimes feel
a bit confused by all the different relationships
and connections within the Zoldyck family,
this seems to have been done on purpose, as
this panel here illustrates pretty well I
think. Now this incremental introduction of
Killua’s family and all its members serves
two larger purposes I believe, firstly, next
to Killua, several of the Zoldycks generally
play a relevant role in several story arcs
and seem to be a major force in the world,
politically and militarily. Secondly and more
importantly I think, Togashi slowly shares
more and more information about Killua’s
past and true personality as an essential
part of his character arc and development,
which we will be discussing in a second. Overall
there are four major themes in Killua’s
past that make him the inhuman person that
we meet at the beginning of the story and
that he needs to overcome throughout his journey
with Gon: Assassination, torture, expectations
& love. So, let’s look at these elements
in a bit more detail.
As the Zoldycks are a family of assassins,
violence and murder are not only part of their
daily business, but of their family identity.
Killua was trained and shaped to become a
top tier assassin basically from the moment
that he was born. Growing up in this kind
of environment, Killua has grown numb to the
act of killing, to the point where he even
seems to be getting a bit of enjoyment out
of it. We can see this for instance in chapter
14 during the Hunter Exam arc, where he grows
frustrated playing ball with Netero and Gon.
At some point he relies more on more on excessive
force, resulting in a kick, that in Netero's
words would be capable of shattering a normal
person's leg. After leaving the game, in his
bloodlust, that had started to overtake him
throughout the match, he releases his frustration
on some unfortunate Hunter examinees that
crossehis path, leaving them dead on the ground
as Killua walks away without so much as a
second glance at them. Thus, his upbringing
has left him with little regard for the value
of life and the use of violence against others.As
part of his training and due to the high expectations
in him, Killua was subjected to countless
tortures by the hands of his family when he
was young. As a result, he became immune to
poison, developed a high tolerance to electricity,
and grew in agility and strength with his
fingernails being able to turn into sharp
claws. But the cruel physical abuse clearly
has left strong marks on him, physically and
mentally. While Killua does in fact try his
best to conceal any signs of the torture and
cruelty he had to endure all his life, slowly
but steadily we learn more and more about
the horrors he had to endure. From Illumi’s
manipulation, to the scars he carries on his
body that we can see during his training with
Biscuit, we finally understand that the horrible
insight we got into Killua’s childhood in
the family house was apparently only the tip
of the iceberg. Here, we actually get a first
glimpse into this, when Milluki is attempting
to torture Killua after running off to take
the Hunter Exam. The fact that he was brutally
tortured at the hand of his own brother didn’t
seem to bother him at all, neither physically
nor mentally. However, while Killua might
have grown numb to his own abuse, he seems
to understand quite clearly that what has
happened to him was terrible. Once he learned
that Gon, Leorio and Kurapika had come for
him, the very notion that his friends could
be threatened placed Killua in an immediately
aggressive disposition where he appeared more
than willing to attack his own brother - something
that Milluki seemed to immediately pick up
on himself - given his troubled expression.
And while this is only one example out of
many, it already does offer us our first implication
of Killua's cripplingly perverted sense of
self-worth. Having known nothing else his
entire life, Killua didn't mind being tortured,
almost as if he felt that for him to experience
this was only natural and entirely acceptable.
And yet he was completely enraged at the thought
that someone else he cared about might have
to endure this very same treatment. So, his
relationship to torture is not only a strong
indicator of Killua’ lack of self-worth,
but also gives a first insight that despite
his cruel past, he still has a natural sense
of morality that lies suppressed under his
numbness - something that his family without
any doubt wished to get rid of. On top of
everything his family did to him or maybe
exactly because of it, Killua also suffers
under the heavy expectations his parents have
in him for becoming the heir to the family
legacy. The Zoldycks are infamous in the Hunter
world for being top-tier assassins, with some
of the most capable fighters in the story,
and yet within this group of monsters it was
Killua that was chosen to one day take over
the family, because he showed the most potential
out of his siblings, including his brother
Illumi. Despite being a true prodigy in terms
of fighting and mastering new skills, something
he demonstrates over and over again side by
side with Gon, Killua has no interest whatsoever
in continuing the family business, which is
quite understandable given how his family
treated him. And it is one of the reasons
that Killua is looking for his own purpose
in life and makes us readers wonder whether
or not he actually has a free will of his
own. And this already brings me to the last
theme of Killua’s childhood: Love. As we
will see again later on in this video, expressing
affection and love is something that Killua
is struggling with throughout the story and
is something he has to learn more about first.
Throughout large parts of the story, Killua
only knows how to show his love for others
by protecting them: Killua tried to protect
Gon countless times during their journey and
was reduced to tears at the thought of failing,
he stood up for Zushi and he even initiated
his friendship with Ikalgo by saving his life,
only to name a few examples. His inexperience
with expressing such emotions comes from the
twisted sense of love that he has experienced
from mostly his mother Kikyo and his brother
Illumi. Kikyo was willing to literally chain
Killua down and beat him if it meant keeping
him "safe”, at least in her eyes. Illumi
meanwhile, in his over-protective and psychopathic
way, went so far as to implant one of his
manipulative Nen needles into Killua without
his knowledge or consent giving him subconscious
orders that dictated his actions throughout
most off the series. Both of their abusive
shows of affection for Killua have most likely
accompanied him all his life and based on
nothing but his own innate sense of morality,
protecting was the only thing he knew to do.
And so, these four elements, assassination,
torture, expectations and love are what I
believe have made Killua the physically strong
and emotionally broken kid that Gon meets
at the hunter entrance exam, and I think that
the Zoldyck family home does a wonderful job
of symbolising all this. The inside of the
house is more akin to a medieval castle decked
out with a modern security system, a torture
room and even a secret room to hide his sister.
Being atop a mountain, it’s quite isolated
and because of the numerous safeguards and
obstacles that separate outsiders from the
family, starting with the Testing Gate, it’s
also easy to see why Killua never had any
friends until he met Gon, assassins’ training
and duties aside, making it painfully clear
why Killua wanted to break free from his family
so badly.Based on the theme of humanity
and the realistic approach Hunter x Hunter
takes on people, it is only understandable
then, that Killua ended up with such a dark,
twisted and insecure perspective after experiencing
so much physical and emotional abuse. And
so I think it is more than fair to say that
the Zoldyck family is the main source of Killua's
need for finding free will, self-worth and
a purpose in life. And so, now that we know
this underlying psychological background,
let’s now look at what happened when Togashi
threw this character into the hunter world.
And what better place to start than the most
important relationship in the story, his friendship
with Gon.
We already talked a little bit about the relationship
between Gon and Killua in the last video.
However, I purposefully decided to save the
majority of it for today, since I think we
need some understanding of both Gon AND Killua
so wen can truly understand and appreciate
their connection in full. The main thing I
think, that makes the friendship between Gon
and Killua so special, is that they have completely
mirrored character arcs - one negative and
the other positive. Gon goes from joyful and
caring at the beginning of the story to numb,
cruel and inhuman towards the end. Killua
meanwhile goes from numb, cruel and inhuman
to joyful and caring. And so, while Gon’s
lowest point is close towards the end of the
story in his brutal murder of Pitou, Killua’s
lowest point in the story is pretty close
towards the beginning, at the end of the hunter
exam. First, as we already mentioned he kills
some of the other hunter examines simply out
of annoyance and bloodlust. And later, during
the final stage, he ends up failing the hunter
exam overall for killing another contender,
manipulated by Illumi and being recaptured
by the claws of his family. He leaves behind
Gon and goes back home with his will and dreams
once again broken. This state of complete
surrender to his family and the cruel act
of murder he commits are the absolute bottom
point for Killua in the entire series, and
from this point onward his arc is on a constant
incline. Ironically enough, it was Gon’s
friendship and original morality that saved
Killua, and Gon’s later moral decline encourages
Killua to question his own morality and views.
Both Gon and Killua had to grow up with no
friends around them and both of them want
to travel the world and become stronger. Thus
the hunter exam was the perfect arc format
to quickly establish a friendship between
these two characters right at the start of
the story in a believable way. Since both
of them were the youngest contenders in a
contest meant for adults, they naturally found
each other, while at the same time highlighting
their uniqueness. While Gon immediately sees
Killua as his friend, given his past and low
sense of self-worth Killua seems to feel like
he has to earn Gon’s friendship first. Thus,
during the final examination he reveals that
all he wants is “for Gon to be his friend!”
without realising that it’s a) not something
he needs to ask for and b) that Gon already
considered him his best friend at that point.
And even though Leorio tells him that he already
is Gon’s friend, under the influence of
his brother, Killua’s spirit breaks and
he sees his dream crushed. In the despair
that overtook him in his brother’s presence,
he apparently defaults to the only thing he’d
ever known in his life, and he kills Botero
in cold blood - without Gon there to stop
him, ultimately returning home, certain that
he after all has no will of his own. And when
Killua is literally chained up again inside
his family home, it once again is Gon who
comes to save him and take him out into the
world - showing Killua that he now truly has
made a real friend. Gon is Killua’s light
in the dark, something that he makes very
clear in this moment here. This - is probably
one of my favourite scenes in the story. It
brings us back to the start of the adventure
before going into the dark part of the chimera
ant arc. It’s just one of many moments where
Killua finds himself the most worthless person
in the world, all while believing that Gon
would be able to lead him to a better life.
And throughout the story, Gon does exactly
that. Gon teaches Killua how to engage in
healthy interactions with other people, how
to express love in different ways, and offers
him a motivation for self-improvement. It
was this motivation that lead Killua to master
Nen and Hatsu to the incredible degree he
does, and ultimately to remove the needle
planted in him by Illumi - finally allowing
his true personality to shine through. Despite
his creeping decline into darkness, for the
kid who came from darkness in the first place,
Gon indeed served as a light to help Killua
navigate it and turn on his own inner light
switch. And ultimately, I think that Killua
seems to have learned from Gon's influence
on himself of being a light to his darkness.
Because, towards the end, we find that Killua
has now taken on the role of being a light
for Alluka. And so, while Gon’s character
arc followed the path of a tragedy, Killua’s
much rather was a journey of redemption. Thus,
Gon’s falling character arc and Killua’s
rising one slowly approach each other until
they finally cross paths during the Greed
island arc, where I would argue both are roughly
on the same moral level and the two boys are
the closest and most similar to each other.
With the beginning of the Chimera Ant arc
however, we see a rapid alienation between
the two. Gon’s arc starts spiralling into
darkness, while Killua’s has a sudden uptake
after removing Illumi’s needle. During the
arc, Gon and Killua’s relationship reaches
its climax and so, despite Killua’s alien
position to the audience at the start of the
series as a young assassin from the notorious
Zoldyck family, he quickly becomes a far easier
reference point than Gon. He starts to see
nuance in situations where Gon only sees his
own twisted sense of black and white. Killua
is the one to save Gon from being killed by
the Chimera Ant early in the arc while Gon
fully unprepared throws himself into combat
in order to get revenge for the death of his
friend. Liberated from Illumi’s influence
and with his new-found sense of free will
and independence, Killua begins to understand
the complex sense of justice and morality
that the world ofHunter x Hunteroperates
on, and increasingly grows worried about Gon’s
single-minded, inflexible approach. When Gon
is supposed to show his resolve to Morel,
he visualizes all the hate and negative emotions
inside him to fuel a frightening attack. In
the last moment, Killua steps in and manages
to pull Gon back from the brink, looking seriously
worried for his friend. Later however, as
Gon vows to kill the innocent bystander Komugi
to get a shot at Pitou for killing Kite, Killua
isn’t able to reach his friend anymore.
Because at this point, Gon doesn’t understand
Killuass true feelings anymore, as he demonstrated
so touchingly after the hunter exam. And so,
when Killua finally reaches him and Pitou,
Gon says this. We can see Killua visibly tensing
up here and being deeply hurt by Gon’s words.
And so, once Gon snaps and trades in his remaining
humanity for violence, Killua fully abandons
his cruel past but still is unable to do anything
but watch in horror. After saving Gon’s
life, both boys decide to go their own ways
and it truly feels like something significant
has changed. It’s a departure in every sense
of the word, and the lingering final shot
of two opposing Gungi pieces overlapping each
other fades away it feels almost impossible
to reconcile the beginning of the show with
the end, with both of them having switched
places.
I think by now we are starting to get a pretty
good idea of Killua and what It is that drives
his character. Killua’s behaviour and actions
over the course of their journey are quite
different from Gon’s, something I think
Togashi wonderfully explains through their
Nen types. Gon is an enhancer, who are simple
and determined. Most of them never lie, hide
nothing, and are very straightforward in their
actions or in their thinking. Their words
and actions are often dominated by their feelings.
They are generally very selfish and focused
on their goals, something that basically describes
Gon pretty perfectly. The same goes for Killua
being a transmuter type. Theyare whimsical,
prone to deceit, and fickle and many tend
to hide their true intentions.This fits Killua
pretty well. After all, who other than a whimsical
Transmuter could be expected to spend 200
million jenny on snacks? Additionally, Killua
is not opposed to lying. Being the genuinely
well-meaning person that he is, he only lies
when necessary as observed by Bisky, yet he
does lie nonetheless. The most notable trait
here however is his extreme inclination to
conceal information. As expressed near the
end of the Yorknew Arc, Killua will choose
to remain ignorant rather than ask a question
that shows his ignorance to others - being
grateful that Gon asked the questions he was
reluctant to. Additionally, despite admiring
Gon so much, he tends to withhold most of
his feeling on thoughts from him. Thus Killua
is quickly embarrassed when Gon draws attention
to their friendship, as the true value of
their bond is something Killua prefers to
keep to himself. The finest example of this
is his heart-wrenching plea to Palm to help
Gon out of his dark mindset. According to
the narrator Killua had intended to lie, here
as well and conceal his true feelings - yet
in a moment of emotional desperation let it
slip. This short act of opening up was so
powerful for him that he simply couldn't conceal
anything in this moment, breaking down into
tears and begging. Also, since many Transmuters
rely on techniques that give unique and unpredictable
properties to their Nen that reflect their
personalities - something we’ll also be
exploring in the next video on Hisoka - I
think Killua’s electricity powers are also
a wonderful representation of his past and
growth at the same time. And so I think it’s
finally time to look at Killua’s character
arc and how his character has developed over
the course of the story.
Differently than Gon, Killua starts into the
story without a clear desire or purpose. His
original desire was to break free from his
family and find his own path, yet since he
manages to do that relatively early on, he
then lacks any specific goal and thus accompanies
Gon on his journey to find his father. That
doesn’t mean that he doesn’t have a drive
though. As we have discussed before, on a
more subconscious level, Killua’s need is
to break free form his brother’s control
to regain his free will, find self-worth and
ultimately a purpose in life, a philosophy
called Ikigai in Japanese.
We have already discussed large parts of the
first half of the story, except for the Orkney
Arc, where Killua is prepared to sacrifice
himself so that Gon can escape the phantom
troupe. What I really want to focus on however,
is Killua’s moment of revelation and the
climax of his arc, the emotional battle with
the chimera ant Rammot. Seeing his friend
be on the verge of death, Killua’s will
to save Gon comes into conflict with his brothers
orders to run away from any wrong opponent.
After once again apologising to Gon for not
being of any use, the friendship and love
he has built towards Gon overpower his brother’s
powers and he is able to remove the needle
that he wasn’t even aware of until that
point. This scene has some striking implications
for Killua, presents the moment of redemption,
and it touches upon all of the themes surrounding
his character. Are we slaves to our birth,
to our genetics, the way our families brought
us up, or the lack of a family? Or, by sheer
force of will and concentrated effort can
we choose to become something different than
what we were and surpass the limitations set
by our upbringing? It's a very personal issue
that ultimately culminates into one central
question: how much agency do we actually have
in our own lives? The needle suddenly gives
us a whole lot of answers about Killua’s
behaviour that have haunted us the entire
series. Finally realising that Killua was
being constantly Manipulated by Illumi suddenly
makes his gruesome choice to kill Bodoro a
bit more understandable. Killua was overwhelmed,
confused, struggling to overcome this subconscious
urge while remaining faithful to his friends.
Feeling caught by his brother and uncertain
of Leorio's chances, Killua decided to gave
up his chances to become a hunter to help
Leorio achieve his dream. his lack of self-worth
also played a role in this choice I believe,
allowing all of his friends but himself to
become a Hunter. And so it is not only a very
cathartic moment for us readers, but also
for Killua himself to find out that his fear
& uselessness was actually caused by Illumi's
Hatsu and not due to his cowardice. As it
turns out, there never was anything wrong
with Killua in the first place - showing us
that he was actually the best friend anyone
could wish for, being as loyal and dependable
in spite of the literal mind control trying
to push him away. And I think that this moment
gives as an even deeper insight into Killua’s
personality. In one regard, it allows us to
see just how far Killua will go for those
he loves. While captured by the Phantom troupe,
surrounded on all sides by some of the most
infamous and dangerous Nen users in the world,
Killua still instinctively began to intervene
in Gon's mistreatment until Hisoka stopped
him. We can only imagine what pressure Killua
must have felt due to the needle in this situation,
how many escape plans were running through
his mind, and yet he was ready to stand up
for his friend in need. For me, this alone
establishes Killua as one of the most protective,
caring, and self-sacrificing characters in
the all of manga. And what I find important
to note here, is that this moment is not the
end for his character arc, but rather a knot
that finally enabled Killua to grow way faster
than before, actually steepening his arc even
more. In the events that follow this scene,
we see Killua stand up to the Royal Guard,
chase down Gon-San, challenge his family,
protect Alluka, and see to Gon's healing.
A true snowball effect of greater and greater
displays of determination, intelligence, and
loyalty only made possible by allowing Killua
to finally be himself. Killua held back by
Illumi’s needle was caught in darkness,
outshone by Gon's light. Once it was removed
however, Killua proved in every way to be
the one shining by far the brightest in their
friendship from that point onward. While Gon
removes himself from all his friends around
him more and more after Kite’s death, Killua
forms countless new relationship over the
course of the chimera ant arc. This goes so
far, that he even befriends one of the ants
itself. Being part of the enemy group, Ikalgo
would have been straightaway killed if this
was Hunter Exam Killua, operating under the
standard practices of the family business.
However at this point, Killua has developed
such a strong sense of morality, compassion
and nuanced decision making that he understands
the ant’s complex situation and ultimately
saves him - exactly the development that Gon
failed to make in this arc. As a result Killua
not only makes a friend, but his kindness
is repaid almost immediately when Ikalgo saves
him after an unsettlingly dangerous game of
darts. The growth Killua undergoes in this
arc is even reflected in his fighting. When
Killua unveils his ultimatehatsutechnique
- Godspeed, on Youpi, who previously was way
stronger than him, it is a striking sign of
how much his character and thus his skills
have grown. While it’s true that Killua
was always a prodigy - able to learn new skills
way faster than normal, and that his cruel
childhood gave him a physical advantage in
other ways, it was his journey with Gon and
ultimately his own innate will and humanity
that enabled one of my favourite character
arcs in general.
And so with the end of the chimera arc, Killua
has finally found his sense of self-worth
and his free will. The only things left for
his arc were breaking fully free from his
family and finding a purpose in life. And
ironically enough, once again it is Gon who
enables this change. Being on the verge of
death after his inhuman transformation, Killua
travels home to ask his little sister Alluka
and the something living inside her to heal
Gon’s wounds. Fittingly to their opposed
character arcs, Killua is the main protagonist
of this last arc in the story, being a much
more relatable hero than Gon was towards the
end. Freeing and traveling with his sister,
Killua finally realises that she is his new
purpose in life and that he can be for Alluka
and Nanika what Gon was for him: A light in
the darkness. And so at the end of his arc,
when he parts ways with Gon to travel with
his sister, Killua has found what Gon has
lost: his humanity and similar to Gon, his
character arc has basically found a complete
end at this point. So should Killua ever return
in to the story, he will need a new arc as
well. The powerful message Togashi is sending
with his character is that you are not bound
by your upbringing but have the freedom to
forge your own path, and that morality and
humanity is something that can bloom even
under the harshest circumstances.
So now that we have discussed the mirror of
Gon’s extreme negative and Killua’s extreme
positive arc, in the next video I want to
discuss a character with a flat character
arc. It is one of the most iconic figures
in Anime and Manga and for a very good reason
often used as the face of the series. Im of
course talking about Hisoka and one of the
most creative antagonists I know. So, stay
tuned for that. Okay, wow I’ve been rambling
forever now. Thanks guys, peace.